ja ich habe das gefühl dass ich in einem
dauerhaften albtraum bilden ich träume
am anfang hat man mir gesagt ein pieks
ja ja das reicht also einmal impfen dann
hieß es der zweite der muss schon sein
damit ist wirklich wirklich sicher ist
und dann hat man lange warten dann nein
also dritter vielleicht israel testet
das aber bei uns nicht und dann doch der
dritte pix und jetzt sagt uns nein nein
drei fixe das reicht leider nicht aus
liebe freunde in deutschland irgendwie
überall die stiko sagt jetzt wir
brauchen vier obwohl beide way karl
lauterbach der gesundheitsminister noch
im januar gesagt hast drei reichen ich
kann sagen als jemand der mittlerweile
zweimal
angesteckte trocken ist mit corona und
gemustert also dreifach geimpft ist es
ein absoluter horror wenn ich jetzt sage
hier noch weiter ein pixel x 56 x und
dann brauche ich vielleicht auch noch
mal wie wir von herrn posten gehört
haben weitere ansteckung also witz
beiseite das macht alles überhaupt
keinen sinn mehr diese politik ist nicht
mehr logisch und interessanterweise
führt sich auch diese nebenpflicht über
die wir gerade gesprochen haben noch
mehr ad absurdum weil vorher dieses in
der debatte nämlich ist braucht die drei
impfung und wenn wir jetzt über viel
sprechen dann weiß ja niemand was in den
nächsten wochen monaten da auf uns
zukommt und vor allem sagen experten
dass wir gar nicht wissen ob dann dieser
impfstoff wirklich wirkt und ob das
nutzen verhältnis wirklich ausgeglichen
er peilt ich stimme dir natürlich zu mit
einer kleinen schlimm mit einem kleinen
unterschied ich finde ja dass du musst
du nur ein stück zweimal ich bin doch
ich war noch nie infiziert nein das muss
ich wirklich sagen und ich verstehe gar
nicht warum nicht ich bin ja immer sehr
am reisen gewesen aber gut ich war
eigentlich sagen will ist ich bin dafür
jeder kann sich impfen also wenn sich
jemand sicherer viel mit der vierten im
vorjahr mit der fünf jahren ist völlig
in ordnung auch genau so wie zum
beispiel auch in unserer redaktion
manche tragen im großraum worum es gehe
ich tue es nicht weil es auch völlig in
ordnung und deswegen auch mit der
impfung ich finde einfach die indirekte
impfpflicht muss enden dass dieses nur
ein mensch mit diesem corona pass darf
dinge machen das muss für mich enden die
indirekte impfpflicht muss enden auch in
england habe ich nicht ein einziges mal
ein crooner zertifikate am ganzen
wochenende vor gezeigt aber wenn jemand
den vierten film ok absolutes muss nur
einmal auf kern ich bin überhaupt nicht
dagegen dass die menschen sich
freiwillig impfen lassen wie gesagt ich
habe mich ja auch impfen lassen und bin
dann trotzdem zweimal erkrankt
dennoch ist es so dass ich finde wenn
die stiko etwas sagt hatte schon so ein
bisschen fast gesetzes mit ja stimmt ja
dabei aber es ist auch eine frage wird
finde ich jedenfalls von vertrauen also
ich finde wenn man irgendwie eine
neuartige sache in sich hinein früher
war das nicht so tätern muss umso mehr
machen und dann tat es weh oder auch
nicht aber es ist eine sache von
vertrauen und ich finde wir haben über
markus söder gesprochen mensch markus
und stellen fest dass das wechselt die
meinung wechseln jeden tag und bei
solchen widersprüchlichkeiten muss ich
mich natürlich fragen ist das vertrauen
bei den menschen die sie angesprochen
haben ist dieses vertrauen überhaupt da
wie stellen politiker überhaupt
vertrauen her für so eine idee eine
maßnahme um eine pandemie zu bekämpfen
die idee ist ja wahrscheinlich gut aber
es ist offensichtlich nicht genug
vertrauen da und das ist verspielt
worden und ich würde sagen eine sache
die vielleicht zu der vierten impfung
oder der fünften sechsten siebten passt
ist die frage wir haben noch studien
gemacht vorher und wieso wussten wir
nicht aus den studien dass nach drei
monaten schon ende ist gelände ist es
nicht überprüft worden das verstehe ich
nicht und das sind ja so
vertrauensfragen die man sich stellt
wenn man dann sagt okay jetzt ok die
wussten es nicht okay jetzt machen wir
drei mal vier mal fünf mal und das darum
geht sie eigentlich vertrauen verspielt
ist ein gutes stichwort ja in ein
wesentlicher punkt in dem was du genannt
dass pauli sie auch die kommunikation
und glaube da ist ein wesentlicher
fehler bis heute wird gemacht von
politikern die aberglauben keine
schwäche eingestehen zu dürfen keine
fehler zuzugeben weil es dann sofort bei
ihnen landet und sie sich dadurch
angreifbar machen es hat niemand du hast
recht hier hat uns gesagt ein pieks zwei
picks reichen und dann den eindruck
zumindest vermittelt gestützt auf
experten das reicht fürs leben war ja
erst dahinter auch gott sei dank gibt es
die impfung da wir sind alle raus die
jenen die sich impfen lassen dann kam
auf einmal der hinweis auf dem booster
dann jetzt der vierte pix und die frage
der haltbarkeit der impfung der dauer
es hat aber nie jemanden in
verantwortung stehend gesagt was mal auf
9 wir haben uns euch damals erzählt zwar
impfungen reichen aus jetzt müssen wir
zu gestehen die erkenntnisse sind
einfach anders also diesen schritt hat
es von keinem noch nicht mal von herrn
lauterbach gegeben es wurde wenn da
überhaupt nur positiv kommuniziert
gesagt der dritte hilft ganz besonders
der vierte ist da auf einmal ist die
zeitspanne der impfungen weg oder
geschrumpft oder dergleichen aber mich
als bürger hat nie jemand mitgenommen
und deswegen gibt es diese enorme
diskrepanz zwischen dem was man gesagt
worden ist und zu dem was ich jetzt
sagen wir okay was kommt denn jetzt
wirklich gelesen da hattrick bella
genesenen hätte ja aus dem home server
ich habe das ein ganz wichtiger punkt
die politik kommt einfach aus dem doktor
allwissend modus nicht raus den sie
sonst gerne hat bei atomausstieges
gesundheitsreformen und anderen
rentenreformen wo sie immer ganz genau
weiß dass das ganz segensreich jetzt was
ihr gerade beschließen obwohl wir in
einer pandemie uns befinden wo
eigentlich selbst die wissenschaftler
jeden tag tasten sich voran bewegt haben
und das ist glaube ich das große problem
dass man die fußgänger glaube ich mal
gesagt die menschen wissen wenig aber
sie haben meistens richtig den eindruck
hatte also so genau wissen dies aber
eigentlich auch nicht und dann kommt
noch hinzu dass man witzigerweise sobald
eine neue variante entdeckt worden ist
gab es schon studiendesign ganz schlimm
ist noch schlimmer wenn man gar nicht
aufpassen dass also wo man sich fragt
komisch wir haben eigentlich die kräuter
über die wirkung impfstoff haben wir
zwei jahre danach noch naja gut also
vielleicht braucht man doch noch mal 4
aber wir wussten innerhalb von zwei
wochen dass omikron eine wand wird und
da denken die leute irgendwie auch im
jahr das seltsame also das schlechte
wissen sie sehr schnell und angeblich
auch ganz sicher und bei dem anderen ist
es ganz seltsam nun ist es ja nichts
neues dass man impfungen gibt es bei
anderen auch selbst bei tollwut oder
muss man auf frischen nach einigen
jahren nur man muss es einfach dann auch
so kommunizieren wie man es weiß sonst
hat man so ein bisschen diese in diesen
fischmarkt effekt mensch 3 im 4 nenn
mich verrückt ich habe noch einen
noch einmal und noch 2
das wirkt dann etwas unernst also im
primär nichts wenn wir jetzt einmal und
zwei gurken geben wenn sie die leute im
vorjahr ja gut ich meine
beratungsmethode da hätte ich jetzt
schon vier beisammen ich
möchte da jetzt nicht weiter darauf
eingehen aber ich glaube auch den fall
dass sich jemand 20 mal hat impfen
lassen für
er ist schon weit vorne dran da macht
man schon sagen ich weiß nicht wie weit
der impfpass reicht nämlich für zeiten
seiten drin sind aber vielleicht wollte
man auch zum impfen mit der nähmaschine
übergehen und ordnung dann hat man schon
perforierten arm aber gut vielleicht
muss man sich mit mit herzchen darüber
retten ja also ich habe wie gesagt ich
habe dazu ja das gesagt und ich finde
das auch sehr spannend es ist ja auch
eine spannende zeit in der wir uns jetzt
gerade bewegen und die entscheidung
ändern sich ja jeden tag man wacht
morgens auf und stellt fest dass es mal
wieder eine andere idee im gange und
solange das so ist und da haben wir uns
ja gerade so unterhalten so lange es
kein ausreichendes
kommunikatives mittel gibt mit den
menschen zu sprechen wird es nix und es
wird ja eigentlich immer eher radikaler
von einer politik die die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen die laufen auf der
straße rum und dann wird von denen
geschimpft die sah ja aber ihr müsst
euch ja impfen lassen und da kann ich
nur sagen das ist ja keine kommunikation
das ist ja gar nichts sie als
informatiker der auch die zahlen fest im
blick hat wie kommen wir aus der
pandemie heraus das kann ich ihnen nicht
sagen da habe ich überhaupt gar keine
idee also ehrlich gesagt wenn ich mir
die zahlen anguckt dann muss ich auch
schon sehr suchen um jetzt noch auf dem
krankenhaus irgendwelche sachen zu
finden da kommen wir ja gleich zu also
wir haben ja keine überlastung des
gesundheitssystems gehabt sondern wir
können ja jetzt zahlen vergleiche
anstellen wir können gucken wie war es
im 2009 10 20 21 und wenn ich ihnen das
sage das kann ich jetzt hier heute nicht
im detail dazu kann man sich ja andere
quellen noch suchen aber wir haben
krankenhausdaten wir wissen ob die
menschen krank waren oder nicht wie
krank sie waren ob sie gestorben sind
wie viele wie viele falsch codiert
worden sind die gar keinen corona hatten
sondern schenkelhals bruch oder sonst
irgendwas und dann uns gezeigt wurden
weil vielleicht unzulänglichkeiten im
krankenhaus system dazu geführt haben
dass er kommt neu dazu das muss man
sagen also jetzt kommen in die statistik
wahrscheinlich durch durch solche
forderungen und ihnen kommen jetzt die
die zahlen derer die im
krankenhaus liegen
als bruch oder so was wie das beispiel
mal zu nehmen die zusätzlich krone haben
aber wegen des oberteils bruches im
krankenhaus kriegen sind jetzt nicht die
meisten ja aber es sind sehr viele
automatische weil jeder testet wurde ein
krankenhaus aber die werden ja in
unseren statistiken geführt ich will
jetzt gar nicht sagen dass der
bürgerwille hinter gesteckt hat aber
wenn sie 70.000 leute im krankenhaus
haben über über zwei jahre die als
corona patienten gerechnet wurden dann
haben wir alle sorge dass da was
passiert und tatsächlich stellen wir
jetzt heute fest die sind alle
asymptomatisch die hatten alle nix mit
krone zu tun aber die hatten positiven
test und was wo zu mussten sie dann ins
krankenhaus weil sie das auch die haben
andere sachen die man halt sagen
der oberschenkelhals wo ist jetzt nur
ein ganz kleiner ausschnitt also
vielleicht hilft es nicht selbst
kurieren zu hause aber